a lot of people in the business do
advertisements and you think well they
just do them because you know you make
some bucks because you actually you
picked a product that's kind of
important to you it is and and it's it's
interesting because I've heard this
about you I chose it for the money to do
oh yeah no no no we all know oh I'm
definitely trolling for money yeah and
let's get the e oh you love the money
but you you chose Febreze exactly
because you like Febreze because you say
that smell is important yes I love I
love smells even like I like I love the
smell of manure and I love the smell of
gasoline mmm I love the smell of
gasoline manure I do yes I love manure
says that you're fertilizing the field
unless it's on my shoe yeah then I'm not
into that right or on your living room
yeah that's a problem exactly and I love
how a person smells hopefully it's a
good thing I mean I even like like my
dad had kind of a sharp smell and I just
I loved that about I mean not the
Cologne or anything like that alone at
all I don't like cologne or perfume I
don't get into it the real smell of a
person do you say cuz I like a great
sense of smell but I don't notice that I
ever I don't think I pay attention to
how a person smells unless they haven't
had a bath in like a week and I notice
it but you actually smell pee I can
smell people I love the smell of my dogs
and yeah and the Guelph's I know I'm
gonna sound like I'm doing a thing for
Febreze but what I love about Febreze is
that the scent that it leaves is so
fresh and it's so lovely because there
are bad cents out there and I actually
am a big fan of it and I use it all the
time okay what does Andy smell like to
you you get a smell from Andy yeah oh
you smell like fresh baby diapers
[Laughter]
they come right out of the wall probably
smelling as my diaper do I have a
particular gotta sit out here for an
hour
there are commercial breaks you can use
the bathroom then yeah it's kind of eggy
there's nothing eggy about me ask your
wife you know a little eggy yes why what
am i why food my wife's gonna watch this
tonight and be cried it's sure well they
call us eggy and diapers the best duo on
television